i remember him coming down the court he
pulled up for three i didn't even look
at the basket i looked in the crowd you
know us walking off the court at home
and seeing them celebrate on our floor
that is a image a memory a feeling that
i'll probably never ever forget if i was
recognizable before the season it has
been magnified times a thousand i was
nervous to go get it checked out i never
want somebody to tell me i can't play
and it's like nobody can win a
championship together until they do it
so i was like yeah we haven't won one so
yeah you could say we can't do it but
you know it's not like we don't have any
time left it goes back to your earlier
question like what do you give up being
jason taylor it's like they exaggerate
everything i do you know those three
four days afterward i was miserable i
really really was i'm not too proud to
say katie's one of the best players ever
so if like one of the best players wants
to work out with you and i could learn
some things for him like why would i say
no well i haven't won a championship yet
and i haven't been an mvp so that's
what's next